[拍手]
改めましてえこんにちはえ教科です
えまず私の自己紹介から少しさせて
いただきますえ僕は
え京都でえ生まれたわけではなく大阪
生まれですそしてえ京都で仕事をするのは
まあ17歳18歳からなんですけども幼少
の頃からですねえ絵を描くのが大好きでえ
1人で絵を描いたりえみんなにえ今日あの
なんかえ上手だねって言われてすごくえ
いい気持ちになってどんどんどんどん絵を
描くことが好きになりましたえゆくゆくは
大人になったら絵かきになりたいなえ
世界中
をスケッチをしてですねえ世界中を回り
たいなそんな子供の頃の思いでしたえでも
16歳の時にですね16歳になってすぐに
え父親が多をします
えーある日突然いなくなりましたそこから
自分で何か自分での力で食べることを考え
なきゃならないそういう思いがすごくひし
と体地を巡りましたえ母親が1人僕は4人
兄弟なので母親が1人でええ4人の兄弟を
大きく育ててくれたんですけどもここから
は自分でやんなきゃていうことで
ええ知人の紹介
でうしで絵を描くまきえっていう義法が
あるんですけどもえよく湿ワだとかえ十箱
にこううしで絵がね描かれてるんですけど
そこへ紹介をしてもらって君映画上手なん
だからここで1回やってみたらどうだて
いうことで僕はへ入ることをものすごく
嬉しく思って高校出るのもそこそこでま
とりあえずは卒業はしたんだけども
とにかく絵がかけるっていうのでうの世界
に飛び込みましただけど入ってみて分かっ
たのはそんなに甘いもんじゃなかったです
えー昔で言うデチ見習いですね固定制度え
今その存在しないえものの教え方なんだ
けどその
厳しい教え方の
最後の世代でし
たで僕の後はあ教科書で学んだりえ
レクチャーをしてもらってえいろんな技術
を学ぶんだけど私たちはやっぱりえそう
いう厳しい世界なのでえ18年間の
キャリアをまず別たこにされました真っ白
にしてから上がってこいそういう世界でし
たそこでえウルシとの関わり合いが始まり
ましたそしてえもう来年で僕50年になり
ますうしと関わってこの50年このうし
っていうものの仕事の中でえ感じたことを
今日は少しだけえお伝えしたいと思って
やってきましたえまずうるしと日本人の
関わり合いていうのは大体1万年前から
始まってますえ縄文人が始めましたねえ
縄文時機にうるしよでコーティングをする
縄文
を壊れたものをうしで接着をする誰が発見
したのかわかんないけどもうしっていうの
はやっぱ1万年前から日本人と関わりがが
ありましたそこから先人たちがうしおをし
てですね日本文化の1つ失って言うんです
けどもそれを確立してきましたそれは江戸
時代まですごい上書き上書きの世界でした
えよくま分かりやすいのは巻ですねえ重箱
にものすごく細かい線が書いてあったりえ
ラデンだとかえ光輝くその装飾を作り出し
ます金覚時よくご存知ですよね金覚時の
金髪もあれは全部ウシの接着力で貼り付け
てますそのベースのうるし塗り
え日本だけじゃなしにアジアっていうのは
木造文化なんです大陸の石文化と違って
木造は腐ってしまいますそれを
コーティングをして何百年何千年持たせる
ためにうしの力を使ってきましたうしで
コーティングするわけですうしイコール
コーティング剤なんだけど日本人がなぜ
こんな素晴らしい紋様え輝きをうしで
作り出したかって言うとまず皆さんえうの
説明をしてくださいっていう時にえうの
説明をなかなかできる人は少ないと思うん
だけどもうしの木から取った受益なんです
よねえこのうの木っていうのは10年間
育てます10年間育てた後傷をつけていき
ますこの傷っていうのは我々で言うと同じ
ですよ
ね切り裂かれるわけですよね傷をつけ
られるわけそこで出てくるのは私たちは
血液が出てきますえー彼たちも
樹液イコール自分の体を保護しよう自分の
体を再生しようとする血液なんですよね
樹液っていうのはその樹液を採取してその
接着力え防布剤としても使いますそれが
うるしですでこれが原料となってえ
いろんなお寺寺院仏学だとかえ神社もそう
ですよねうんとお寺の調度品我々の生活の
中にあるうるしの製品湿ワだとかあ重箱
ですね先ほどから言うそれはこのうるしで
全てコーティされてますだからこそ数百年
え数千年えこの木造でありながらやっぱり
え耐久性を保つそれがうの役割ですだけど
日本人がこのうを使うことによって何を
感じたか僕は50年間の間でえ200年前
の仕事を200年後に送るそのバトン役と
してえ50年間見て感じたことは大切に
長く使ってもらうそれがこのうしの気の
寿命命と交換をしたお礼ですよね感謝の
気持ちです10年育ててこのうの木は傷を
つけられて血液を全部取られて6ヶ月で命
を閉じてしまいますそこへ日本人はどう
やって感謝の気持ちを表そうか共存をして
いくためにはどうやってえこれを続けて
いこうかそれは感謝の気持ち長なく大切に
使ってあげるっていうことですそのために
素晴らしい紋様を作り出します特別なもの
を作り出しますそれが日本文化の心髄です
それはうの世界だけではなくてえーま
ファブリックですよねえ織り物の世界も
そうだし神の世界もそうだしいろんな日本
文化全てが自然の素材を頂いてそれで
えー私たちの生活に役立ててますそこが
日本人のやっぱりえ1番深いえ精神性だと
思って
ますそれを上書きできたのは僕は日本だけ
じゃないかなと思ってますていうのはま
大陸の文化っていうのはあ1つの時代が
わるとまた新しいものを作るんだけども
日本の文化っていうのはベースをの上に
上書きですベースの上に上書きそれが
ずっと続いてえ素晴らしい日本文化ができ
たように思いますえただですねそれ
は近年までの話です
ね共存地域地域の共存を目指した人たちが
グローバルになっちゃいました日本だけ
じゃない世界中が同じもので生活ができる
ようになりました近代文化です素晴らしい
文化なんです前前行く文化素晴らしい
スピードで走ってますそれはものすごく僕
も素晴らしいことだと思ってる
ただ僕たちみたいな職人が手作りで時間を
かけて作るものがどんどんどんどん
追い込まれてきましたそれがこの100年
ですねえま資本主義えお金儲けものすごく
大事なんですよお金があるからいろんな
取り組みができるうんいろんなところへ
進んでいけるそれも大事なんだ
けど僕はこの50年でそれがあまりにも
バランスが悪いんじゃないかっていうこと
にきましたえ元々文化財の
修復人仏学の修復え待末端のえ皆さんの
うしの長道品その修理をずっとしてきて
ですね本当に僕たちがいなくなっても
大丈夫なんだろうかっていうことに気づき
始めまし
たAIたちが
作る新しいえこれからの製品ですね長道品
え身の前のものそれは素晴らしくうん安価
でたくさん一気に作れますだけど本当に
それだけでいいんですかっていう風なこと
を思い出してそれが10年前です金次に
シフトしたのは10年前なんです金次は
なぜいいのかみんなと一緒にできるから
ですお寺の修理仏像の修理200年前の
すごいクオリティのものを一般の人とは
できないだから一般の人にそれを知ら
せようとして僕は金築にシフトしました
おかげでこの10年間でいろんな方々があ
うちに来られて金次をしながらですねえ
古典的な
あ文化の話をしました日本文化だけでは
ないです諸が国えまイタリアはイタリア
フランスはフランスえドイツはドイツえ
インドネシアはインドネシアそれぞれ自国
の文化がありますそれは一体誰が作ってき
たんでしょうかビジネスマンではないです
よ
手作りをしてきた職人さんたちですその人
たちが地獄の文化を作ってきましたそれが
なかなか今は前に出ることができなくなり
ましたそれは時間がかかって僕たちはお金
儲けには適さない人間になってしまいまし
たそこで金次を利用して本当にこうなんだ
と元々の手作り文化元々の植林文化をもう
1度取り戻さなきゃなんないんじゃないか
僕はそのことを伝え続けまし
た僕が仕事をするためには先ほどうを書い
てくれる職人さんそれは書きこって言って
ですねうるしを書くのが専門ですそれを
生成する人それをチューブに詰める人これ
全部職人さん
です今出てるこの方は僕がうるしのライン
を引く面相筆っていうね特殊な筆を作る
職人さんですでこの人の周りにはこのはイ
の毛だとかたぬきの毛え動物の毛を利用し
て筆を作りますそうするとこの人は筆は
作れるんだけどイを集めることはできませ
んイの川を剥ぐことはできません毛を
束ねるそれもできませんこの人の周りにも
何にもの職人さんがいますその職人さんの
集まりがいてくれて初めて僕が仕事をでき
るっていうことですそれを1つの
工場で作ることは今の文化は可能なんです
だけど本当にそれだけでいいですか本当に
僕たちがいなくなっていいんですかって
いうことが今回
の聞いてほしいえ第1のクエスチョンです
よねそれは僕の判断だけじゃなし皆さんで
判断してほしいえそこがあ今日の1番伝え
たいことですえ金っていうのはそのうの
接着剤を利用してですねれたかけたりえ
壊れたものをもう1度うしで接着をして
うんそこへ金の装飾をします使う道具材料
っていうのは自然のものしか私は使いませ
んこれは接着剤でもできるんですよね壊れ
たものを元へ戻すくっつけるそれはあ接着
剤でも大丈夫ですだけどどうでしょう
か外国でま去年からですねイタリア
バチカン市えいろんなところで公演をさせ
てもらいましたおかげでやっと日本の国が
応援をしてくれるようになって送り出して
くれましたそこでもこの話をします本当に
それでいいんでしょうか接着剤だけでいい
んでしょうか残念ながらヨーロッパって
いうのはうしの気は生息しませ
んアジア中心ですよねで彼たちは修復は
ケミカルなんですよねでもやっぱり彼たち
も気づき始めてます本当にそれだけでいい
んだろうかっていうことはあバチカンもの
各美術館もえ同じことを私に伝えてくれ
まし
た将来解決のできないことをひょっとし
たら残しすぎてないかっていうことですよ
ね私たちはいいですよ今ね便利で
えいあのおかげでいい生活はできてますお
金儲けをする人たちも設けてますだけど
そのツが必ず回ってくるっていう風に僕は
考えてます海底でよくね今騒がれてる
マイクロプラスチックのことだとか
え
ま空気中にも富有してるようなえ微粒子の
石油製品だと
かその原因を作ってるのは今僕たちじゃ
ないかなっていうそういうことを思い始め
まし
た
え行くとこ行くところでよく僕は聞かのは
100年先清川さんの見解はどうですか
100年先の未来をどう考えますか
どんなことをしたら素晴らしい100年先
が作れますかよく聞かれ
ます100年前の仕事を100年先に送る
仕事その中で感じたことを教えて欲しいん
だていうことです僕はその時の答えはいつ
も一緒なんです100年先を本当に見る
見ようとするなら100年先に勇気を持っ
て戻ってください100年前その時にでき
てたことそれが今できないんですよ材料も
道具もないそれを賄う職人さんたちの数も
いないそれは僕は経験の中で感じまし
たそこ
をしてもらうことでこの100年間で何を
みんなが手に入れて何をなくしちゃたか
そこをもう1度確認しようよそれが良くも
悪く
も素晴らしいスピードで走ってきたこの
年おそらく大切なものをなくしてないです
すかっていうのが僕の意見
です前ばかり見るんじゃなくて今から大事
な100年それを作るために100年前に
戻ることそれがとても大事なんだていうお
話をし
ますみんなが感動してくれます本当だよね
そうだそうだそれをもう1回確かめて
みようこれが僕の今日の最大のプレゼン
ですどう取るかは皆さん次第だと思って
ます僕は100年先の未来を作る現場には
入れないですだけどヒントはここで皆さん
にプレゼントできると思い
ます作り出すもの縄文時代から始まって
ます縄文時を見てください
え各国の昔の素晴らしい1万年前のもの
たくさんのものが残ってますその関成と
あるもの素晴らしいものですよ周りに何も
ない道具も1つもない材料もないそんな中
で素晴らしいデザインだとか
素晴らしいヒントが彼たちは残してくれて
ますそれがどんどんどんどんその感性が
なくなっていくAIたちに感性は真似は
できないと思ってます僕たち人間の手から
作るものそれはとても大事です近代文化
ものすごく大事なんですよすごいスピード
で走ってますだけど古典文化僕たちのよう
な古いものを
お直したり作ったり作り直すことのできる
古典文化もバランスよく残さなきゃいい
未来はできないと思ってますそれは日本
だけじゃなく各国共通だと思います世界中
がそうだと思います僕はそのことを
ヨーロッパで発信し続けてきましたうん
これからあと何年できるかわかんないです
けどもそれを発信し続けますまたどこかで
会えることを楽しみにしてます今日はどう
もありがとうございまし
た